hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
February is upon us yet again and now
the winter lull is moving away the
bigger titles are beginning to release
and just as I intended to talk about
Ironman VR that has now been rescheduled
for a May release instead and the amount
of games that have been delayed this
year is mind-blowing
but we won't let that bring us down new
games February 2020 let's do this I'm
starting with a game which I would love
your opinion on have you heard of Dreams
dreams has the potential to be the game
which changes video games forever that
may sound like a lofty claim but hear me
out drinks is split into two halves the
playing aspect and the creative aspect
did you ever play a game called
LittleBigPlanet back then we could
create our own levels and have millions
of people enjoy them dreams is that
concept but heightened and evolved into
everything you see on screen right now
I've seen people recreate their favorite
games with breathtaking accuracy such as
the hallway from silent Hills PT another
person in the beta created a remix of
Sonic Adventure from the Dreamcast can
you see why I'm excited to see what the
community create next any genre is
possible here anything you can imagine
whatever we dream we can create dream
drops on ps4 On February 14th and talks
have already begun about a PC release in
the near future I'll keep you up to date
with that one I'll be sure to demo some
of the greatest levels I can find each
month after release but the real
question is does dreams interest you at
all I admit I'm kind of hyped
[Music]
next up we have zombie army for dead
waah
yeah you're not seeing things Hitler has
summoned zombie Nazis the game is set in
an alternative timeline to our own in
1946 a year after Adolf initiated plans
a clumsy which we lovingly call the
zombie hog I've been playing zombie army
for this week and I have to admit I was
expecting a mindless shooter but I was
pleasantly surprised by some of the
mechanics for example zombies you've
taken down and motorized can be
reawakened to prevent this from
happening we go for a good old head
stomp it 100% is guaranteed to stop this
happening the enemy types evolved over
time with helmets to protect their domes
and high level bosses with unique
weaknesses on top of this there are
interactable elements in each mission
such as get this electrifying a zombie
shark into action
speaking of electrifying zombies weapon
attachments and upgrades allow us to
change our own loadout with pretty
devastating effects and then we have the
good old sniper elite moments with
slow-mo bullet time x-ray gah with both
a solo campaign with up to 4 players and
a horde mode which brings back the call
of duty zombies nostalgia this seemingly
b-movie spin-off has more under the hood
then I personally expected February the
4th if you're interested on ps4 Xbox and
PC
[Music]
oh hello how about a hospital simulator
this is two-point hospital finally
making its way over to console on
February 25th if you've ever played
themed Hospital you know what to expect
here build your own hospital from the
ground up and invest in different
treatments for your patients of course
these aren't real world issues
you'll be curing lightheadedness by
literally decapitating your patients and
reassembling them afterwards there is an
illness known as a pandemic which
involves a kitchen pan on multiple
patients heads yes that kinda came in
some scenarios your help won't be enough
and the ghosts will haunt your hospital
is a quick pro tip hire janitors with
the ghosts capture skill to get rid of
the undead fictitious illnesses are
everywhere and you're the only one with
the OCD skills needed to keep this
hospital running your managerial skills
will be tested massively on February
25th on ps4 Xbox one oh and on the
switch - that's impressive
let's include an update to a
pre-existing game here
apex legends one year ago this game
smashed a hole in everything and became
one of the biggest games of the year
without any fanfare at all now one year
on season 4 is going to drop on February
4th with a brand new character which can
be bought or you can earn it in-game for
free and he's a thick boy
we need more thick people in video games
the season is named assimilation and
will bring in new weapons new regular
content and an update to the
pre-existing maps I don't know about you
but I'm a sucker for a map update I'm
seriously thinking about jumping back in
do you still play or are you
contemplating returning I love to know
your thoughts the dark side this series
has been difficult to surmise in the
past part puzzle game part button
bashing extravaganza and part souls bond
each game release changes our
expectations
well that's happening again with
Darksiders genesis this time it's the
camera which has changed the most
looking like a diablo clone at first it
quickly becomes apparent genesis is
trying to keep the elements from
previous games which have proved
successful so ultimately this is a
role-playing hack and slash title in
terms of the story Genesis is a prequel
to the core series following strife one
of the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
usually accompanied by his brother war
PC gamers have had this for a few months
and now on February 14 ps4 Xbox one and
switch gamers will get their chance to
journey back into hell
one of the most long-running fighting
games returns with one of the most
complete editions ever assembled this is
Street Fighter 5 champion edition by now
we all know how Street Fighter works so
let's not start that instead here's the
main bullet points there have been so
many versions of Street Fighter over the
years it's been impossible to keep up
arcade editions seasons being added with
more content
well Street Fighter 5 champion Edition
has pretty much everything forty
characters are included in this outing
forty this will take a long time to
master on top of that our 34 stages and
arenas to do battle in and now we live
in the world of cosmetic items the
Street Fighter 5 champion Edition has
over 200 to try on with new cinematics
new gameplay modes and all at a
discounted price Street Fighter 5
champion Edition could be the game for
you February 14th if you are interested
[Music]
as I've already spoken about zombie
Hitler this video is likely to be
demonetized so let's talk about another
non child-friendly game infliction
extended cut ultimately an updated and
polished version of the 2018 game which
never made it to consoles infliction
puts us inside an interactive nightmare
uncovering heartbreaking secrets and
hidden messages all whilst being scared
to death
operating quite like outlast hiding
under tables and beds to prevent being
spotted is a key way to play but we also
can be more aggressive with the camera
flash used to stun the spirits you
encounter on February 25th on ps4 Xbox
one and switch with a PC release coming
later in the year so there we have it
eight new games dropping in the month of
February 20 20 does anything flow to
your boat I think I'll be jumping into
two-point Hospital and of course taking
on Hitler's a zombie hogs what will you
be playing I'll be in the comments
lurking I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]